this year we have 328 women on the list
that's up from 241 last year
as a group these women are worth nearly
1.5
trillion dollars and that's a nearly 60
percent
increase since last year the past year
has been very interesting
especially in terms of the stock market
last time forbes
finalized its billionaires list it was
during
this stock market crash and a year later
you see that the stock market has
rebounded and that really
has affected a lot of net worths in the
world
including of women so they collectively
added
570.7 billion dollars to their wealth
and that is largely due to the
rebounding stock markets across the
globe
the richest woman in the world is
francoise betancourt myers
and she's worth 73.6 billion dollars
she is an heiress herself who is on the
board
of the business that was founded by her
grandfather
l'oreal so she inherited her wealth from
her mother
lilian who died in 2017 and
francoise and her family own a 33 stake
in the business
and the l'oreal stock has been up 40
percent
since last march that has helped add
nearly 25 billion dollars to her net
worth
number three on our list actually has a
very interesting story
and that's mackenzie scott she got her
steak in amazon
back in 2019 after she divorced jeff
bezos
and unlike jeff bezos she took a
different route and she said that she's
going to
focus on giving her fortune away
and she's worked on fulfilling that
promise and in the past year
she has given away 5.8 billion dollars
to 500 different organizations
that's a huge philanthropic effort all
that said
she still ended the year 50
richer than she was a year ago and
that's because
amazon stock in the past year has
increased 64 percent
there are also a lot of very interesting
newcomers to our list
one of them is whitney wolfheart who
founded bumble in 2014
and she took the company public in
february
and she became the youngest self-made
woman
billionaire in the world and she's worth
1.3 billion dollars
there's also another newcomer and that
is kim kardashian
kim kardashian is now worth 1 billion
dollars and she owes most of her fortune
to
two big companies that she has one of
them is her kkw
cosmetics which is her cosmetics company
and the other one
is skims which is her loungewear
shapewear and
underwear company i think what's really
interesting to me about the list is that
this year we have a record number of
billionaires we have
2755 billionaires and of all
of those billionaires only 328 are women
so in terms of women building their
fortunes whether that be inherited
wealth
or self-made fortunes we're still
not quite there but looking at the
trends we can see that women
entrepreneurs have picked
up pace they are taking their companies
public
and we're for sure going to see more
women on this list going forward
you